on the field for their moves and everything they thought this was the most comfortable
to be able to now it's um now it's seven which is here why defenses are more spread out
they're taking up more real estate on the field through high balls and different attack approaches
which is fine so so from here my i'm relying on my mechanics here to be able to get that ball
where it needs to get to okay so we're going to do three meters a three meter pass here
which is right here just so you guys know none of tony's fingers work and his passes
his pass is absolutely perfect because of the technique you can you can practice on your thing
like this square to you if you want to take my head off i got eyes on you i know you make it
be games i coach the jews love the boys i got deep down on yours heads on hips
i got it i got it switch thank you don't take a step okay
you might see my target hands don't see your hands here see that frank
nice again here we go they're coming squared you can do that on your own
okay i'd much rather you do this and everybody's like you know and yeah you know there's a little
bit of on saturday night
yeah
bit of a drab lateness
so you know yeah
okay
mark out three meters
it's nail ten
nail ten here
okay
i'm going to put my wrist there now
they're strong
i don't need to i don't need to spin it
i just need to get the ball into his hands
alright
now i'm going to look at you
and see if it gets you
okay
not bad you're supposed to say not bad